[MUSIC PLAYING]
OLIVIER VAN GOETHEM:
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for joining to
listen to our talk,
which will be about
how to analyze
gaming data using Google Cloud.
I will cover the theory behind
some of the Google Cloud
products and services.
And I'll then hand over to
Luke from Improbable, who'll
talk about what they've built
in terms of real world data
analytics pipelines.
This solution that they built
has also been open sourced,
so you can go check
it out afterwards
In an era of free-to-play
and online multiplayer games,
data has become crucial to
understanding and improving
your game.
The ability to collect, analyze,
and derive insights from data
has effects across the entire
value chain of your game.
And this is
everything from being
able to create better
game levels through play
testing using AIs
that have been trained
on the behavior of
real world gamers
to improving monetization
outcomes through better
customer segmentation
and tailored offers.
Organizations also want
to be able to share
data across the different
units from the game developers
to the marketing teams.
And this needs to be
done in a secure manner.
Data is typically stored
in a data warehouse.
However, talking to various
teams in the industry,
we've discovered
that they struggle
to achieve their goals of
analyzing the gaming events
and data that you collect.
This is mainly due to challenges
around the scalability
and cost of legacy data
warehouse solutions.
For example, those
solutions struggle
to handle the exponential
growth of data
that we're seeing
in the industry.
It's also more and more
difficult to integrate
between the various external
sources that you pull from.
And with more and more games
moving to real time telemetry
feeds, being able to analyze,
ingest, and process those
becomes even harder.
So really the question is,
is there a platform out there
that can scale to the
needs of your game?
Hey, everyone.
My name is Olivier Van Goethem.
And I work a Google Cloud
as a customer engineer.
We'll now dig a bit deeper into
the topic of data analytics
and look at one of our
key products in this area.
And that product is BigQuery,
our Cloud native data
warehouse.
BigQuery is fully managed
and serverless and offers
everything that you'd expect
from a data warehouse.
It also has key
unique capabilities,
such as the ability to ingest
and analyze real time streaming
data.
BigQuery also has a high
speed in-memory cache,
which we call BI Engine for
faster reporting and analysis
using tools such as Tableau.
Security is also very important
for us and our customers.
That is why all data is
encrypted at rest by default.
However, one of the most
exciting capabilities
of BigQuery is its built-in
machine learning training
and prediction capabilities.
Let's have a look at those.
So BigQuery ML enables
data analysts to build
and deploy machine learning
models on massive data
sets directly inside BigQuery
using just the power of SQL.
BigQuery ML has the capability
of addressing various use
cases.
For example, you're able
to segment customers using
K-means clustering models.
You can determine a
player's lifetime value
using linear regression.
And you can definitely create
more funky complex use cases
by training external TensorFlow
models somewhere and directly
importing that into BigQuery
and making use of it
to predict using
BigQuery ML and SQL.
So let's have a look
at it in practice.
So let's imagine a
table in BigQuery
that contains game of purchase
and playing time data.
Here we've aggregated
these data points
to have a single
row per user ID that
contains values for their
total number of game purchases
and total hours of playing time.
We've been asked by
the marketing team
to segment these users,
so that we can identify
our most valuable customers.
To do this, I can use BigQuery
ML's K-means clustering
model, all done, again, using
just a simple SQL statement.
I configure the model
to segment our user base
into four categories.
And then I pass in the
data from the table
that I was showing previously.
Once the model has
been trained, I
can check the model evaluation
to validate its output.
BigQuery ML automatically
splits the data
we feed into the
training step, such
that 80% is used
to train our model
and 20% is used to test it.
Here, we can see
that we've identified
the key characteristics
for our four segments.
So for example, we're going
to have our first group.
They purchase a few games,
but play a lot of them.
We see a group of people
who purchase a lot of games
and then play a
lot of those games.
Then we have a group who
just dabble in video games,
purchase very few games and
also play them very little.
And then the final group, which
is the one that I probably
belong in, which is I buy
a lot of games during sales
and never play them at all.
BigQuery is only one piece of
Google Cloud's smart analytics
platform.
Google's platform enables you
to build much broader data
pipelines by
connecting, analyzing,
and visualizing your data across
your applications and systems.
This means we bring you the
best of Google in our solutions.
And we can help
you create a more
innovative and collaborative
culture in your organization.
A Google Cloud
Analytics platform
can also be combined
with compute services
to build out a full-blown
gaming architecture.
For example, you can use
App Engine and Firestore
to manage user profiles and
handle log-ins and log-outs.
You can also use Kubernetes
Engine to host a matchmaking
service and your game servers.
And finally you can,
from those systems above,
send all of the events
and telemetry directly
into BigQuery for analysis.
As I mentioned, for
a real world example,
I'm now going to
hand over to Loek,
who will talk about what
they are doing at Improbable.
LOEK LANDZAAT: Hi, guys.
So as Olivier said, I'm Loek.
I'm a data scientist
at Improbable.
So first, a little bit about
us, who we are, and what we do.
We provide better ways
to make multiplayer games
and help multiplayer
developers meet any challenge.
So how do we do that?
We've got several
services, some of which
include, for instance, managed
hosting and orchestration
of the game servers.
We also have networking
products that
could allow you to combine
multiple game engines,
so you can do more than what a
single engine can currently do.
We've got online services,
such as analytics.
And I'm going to be
talking about that one
in particular today.
And then we still have other
development tools, as well as
everything from
advice and support
to full code development
of your game.
Finally, we now also have
three internal game studios
that are building multiplayer
games using the services
and products that
I just outlined.
And our first
internal game called
"Scavengers" is going to
be out later this year.
So keep an eye out for that one.
So the Analytics
Pipeline, what is it?
And why did we build it?
While out in the field
talking to game studios,
we kind of noticed
that there wasn't
an easy way for them to quickly
get going with analytics.
So we kind of set
out to solve that
by providing a reference
architecture that
is just like deploying
your own cloud model,
so you could quickly could
get going with analytics.
And one of the key
tenants that we
kept in the back
of our heads was
that we wanted to give studios
full access of their own data
without any form of lock-in.
So the key principle
is you just deploying
this in your own cloud.
All the data comes
into your own cloud,
hosting your own kind
of like blob storage.
And as of that
point, you can then
decide to do whatever
you want with it, which
could be, for instance, using an
off-the-shelf live ops or game
analytics provider.
But you still have
the flexibility
then to un-live data, also
utilize any of the ML or AI
tools provided by Google
Cloud in this case.
So why Google Cloud?
They provide highly
scalable analytics.
For instance, you can process
millions of events per second
with Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
They're very easy to use.
So at Improbable, we're
a big user of Kubernetes.
And you kind of have this first
classic Kubernetes experience
when developing on Google Cloud.
They're also fully supported by
Terraform, which is our DevOps
templating language of choice.
And they've got
great documentation
for all the bricks
that they provide.
Also with example code
snippets in various languages.
So if you kind of want to
prototype something quickly,
you can just copy, paste
those, get it to work.
And then if you think
there's something there,
you can afterwards then
make the code your own.
And then in particular
for analytics,
they've got a great stack of
AI and machine learning tools.
So like Olivier just
outlined before--
BigQuery ML.
But if you have many models that
you want to train and deploy
in production, you could use
the AI platform for that,
for instance.
So ingesting data using
the analytics pipeline,
the big picture is as follows.
On the left-hand side, we
have things that emit events.
They could be PCs,
consoles, mobile devices,
game events from other
sources, systems, or whatnot.
Those post or send
all their events
to the analytics pipeline.
And the goal of the
analytics pipeline
is just to capture and persist
and organize all of that data
in your own cloud hosting.
And that then kind of
makes it ready to be
used by any other service in the
future, such as Cloud Dataprep,
to prepare for machine learning
models, BigQuery ML, Cloud
AutoML, et cetera, or just to
analyze that data with BigQuery
and feed it into reporting
systems like Tableau, Looker,
et cetera.
So the architecture
starts with events.
They're JSON events that
are posted to a REST API.
That is a Python 3
application adhering
to the flash programming model.
It is deployed on
Kubernetes Engine.
So that means that, if
the influx of events
kind of enhances,
Kubernetes can auto scale
copies of that application
to however much it needs
to meet those requirements.
So it's horizontally scalable.
When those events
arrive, it kind of
augments them a little bit
between the received timestamp
and then writes a new line
delimited JSON in blob storage.
So once all your data is neatly
aggregated in that blob storage
bucket, you're kind of done.
Because you can then use
BigQuery to actually query data
that's inside of that
bucket in a federated way.
Federated means that
the data doesn't
live inside of BigQuery,
but somewhere else.
But you can still
use SQL statements
on top of data that is
in new line delimited
JSON in Cloud Storage.
Over time, you might
notice that, OK, I actually
have a lot of events coming in.
Each post request becomes
a file in Cloud storage.
So my queries are slowing down,
because I have so many files.
So the first way you
can solve for that
is by using a cloud function
that basically gets invoked.
Whenever a file
hits this bucket,
the function gets invoked.
It takes the contents of
that file from blob storage
and then writes into
native BigQuery storage.
So at that point, if you
then query those tables that
are in native storage,
all your queries kind of
benefit from the native
performance of BigQuery.
So everything will
be super again.
Another way, which isn't
in the open source repo,
but we've added ourselves
when load testing this,
is add in a batch job.
So if you use Dataflow for
this, that comes in every hour
and picks up all the latest
small files in the first bucket
and then aggregates them into
a second final resting place,
where we then have far fewer,
but much larger, files.
And if you then query those in
a federated way with BigQuery,
everything will become
much bigger again.
So we have successfully
scaled this infrastructure
to 10,000 requests per
second at an average of one
server or client request 30
seconds, which is something
that you can tweak yourself
based on your capacity and peak
CCU.
This would support a peak
CCU of about 300,000.
We also tested this
with an average payload
of 10 events per request.
So this would equal 8.6
billion events per day.
So there's two caveats
when using this at scale.
One is you probably really
want to use a similar batching
setup as we have.
And the second is, in order
to further optimize this,
we add a caching error
at the end point,
so that not each post
request becomes a file.
But every 10 seconds,
it flushes out
all the post requests in a
single file and Cloud storage.
So what are some of the
strengths of this setup?
So as I outlined, it's
designed in a modular way
to handle evolving
business needs.
It's super simple to start.
You just start
with an end point,
and then write
into Cloud Storage.
Then if your demand
overtime enhances,
because you run more play
tests or you have more players,
you could, for instance,
use the Cloud Function
to hop all of those events over
into native BigQuery storage,
or you can add a
batching step like we
did to concatenate these files
into fewer, but larger, ones.
You have a flexible and
custom REST endpoint
as an entry point, which
is set up to handle,
for instance, any event,
schema, or source.
So what we've done is we've
got a PlayFab event schema
parser and just one for
our own event schema.
And as events come in,
it just figures out
which parser to use and
then write everything
in the same format
in cloud storage.
And we also preserve
flexibility where possible.
So we use new line delimited
JSON and blob storage.
That's really the key.
And we've got Kubernetes
and Docker, for instance,
utilized where possible.
We've used a single
language, Python 3,
which is very popular
within the data community.
It will also help.
If you've got data analysts that
are kind of engineering savvy,
they can also then look
at the pipeline code
and understand what's going on.
So that's great.
It's affordable.
Because this is a deploying
your own cloud kind of delivery
model, you avoid any
margin that comes
with an off-the-shelf solution.
So what are some of
the opportunities
that we still have?
We could reduce the
maintenance overhead
by deploying the end
point, for instance,
serverless on
Knative or Cloud Run.
This way you don't have to
manage your own Kubernetes
cluster and have the overhead
associated with that.
You could also use the end
point to forward events
to a messaging
queue, for instance.
So you add a method.
So instead of a v1 event,
which goes into Cloud Storage,
you do v1 stream.
And it goes either
to Kafka or Pub/Sub.
And then you can
use that as a source
for, for instance,
a Dataflow streaming
job that can keep a rolling
count of, say, kills.
And if that spikes
or surges, then you
can trigger a blood
moon in your world.
So that kind of then
enables this interplay
between what the players
do in your ecosystem
and how the ecosystem responds
to that on a higher level.
So what are some of the
weaknesses of this setup?
It's that it does require
a data engineering
capacity to maintain.
There is some complexity.
This is not a fully
managed service.
The end point will
definitely benefit
if you would port it over
to a language like Go,
but at the cost then, again,
of interpretability for some
of the data folks out there.
At high scale, you will
have a large number
of small files in
cloud storage that
will then disable the live
external storage functionality.
So at that point, you should
either use a Cloud Function
at the batching step
or at the caching layer
in order to solve for that.
So threats, we've got an
ever-evolving data landscape.
So with new things
that come out,
those might challenge
some decisions
that we've made with
this infrastructure.
So what are some of
the lessons learned?
One of the things
that we have right
now is our own kind
of event schema.
So on the wire when you
send these JSON events,
what is inside of each event?
I'm not going to list all
of these out one by one.
You can look at the slides later
and figure out what each means.
But one thing that
I wanted to explain
is that we've kind
of identified these
as the only keys that
can be at the top level
of your dictionary.
Anything else would go
into event attributes.
So for instance, if it's
a match start event,
the match ID would sit
inside of event attributes.
But by always having only these
kind of keys at the root level,
you can safely unpack
these, for instance,
in your first table
in a data warehouse
when you ingest that somewhere.
And that will
dramatically kind of like
simplify the
ingestion frameworks
that you will have to use if you
want to move that data, ongoing
in the data warehouse.
So about instrumentation,
automatically
enrich incoming
events where possible.
So capture things like the event
time stamp, the event index all
automatically, only
requiring a developer
to pass in what is unique
to that particular event.
Batch your events.
Don't send single events.
If you can, always
batch them up.
And then at what rate
you can flush those out
is informed by, on the one hand,
the capacity you've provisioned
for in terms of
requests per second
versus the number of
peaks you seem to expect.
You can kind of model
out, OK, well, then I
can at most flush x amount
of time per seconds.
Keep a local cache
on the client side
in case of connectivity
disruptions,
then write them to a file.
And then whenever a
connection is re-established,
you can flush everything out.
Make your ingestion
end point configurable.
So for instance, which host,
headers, or query strings
to use for this
particular post request?
And in particular, the end
point reads the query parameters
of many of them.
And they kind of co-determine
the ultimate file path
that the file's stored
in in the Cloud Storage.
So you can then basically
already organize and filter out
certain event types and put
them in neat constructed folders
in Cloud Storage.
This can have beneficial
downstream effects.
Because then I could
write, for instance, all
my frames per second events
to a particular directory
only containing such events.
And then I can aggregate
those before I write them
into BigQuery-- for instance,
in a [INAUDIBLE] table.
So we're using HTTP end points.
So it's always good to have
retries with exponential
back off.
If you don't get
a 200 code back,
just wait a particular
period and then try again.
Some of the tips and tricks
that we picked up on as well
when actually
utilizing this data
is that you can import a Google
spreadsheet as a live BigQuery
table.
Live-- meaning, if I make
changes to the spreadsheet,
they're instantly visible
in BigQuery as well.
And that can be
great, for instance,
if you've got item ID to
item name mapping tables.
Then vice versa, you can
also run BigQuery queries
within Google Spreadsheets.
And a result of that becomes
a spreadsheet as well.
So this is a great way for,
for instance, business analysts
to still use production
data in BigQuery,
but in a spreadsheeting system
that they are familiar with.
You should also check out
the BigQuery JSON function
to extract data out
of event attributes.
Don't use any of the
string lookup functions.
Just use those functions.
Because then you can just
give it a parsing path
and cleanly and exactly parse
the JSON in however you want.
Also, avoid
non-alphabetic characters
in JSON keys, because that will
trip up the federated query
mechanism that I
outlined earlier.
So then finally, we
use DBT to manage
and source control
all of our SQL code
and to document
everything as well.
DBT kind of out of the box
makes every query a model.
And then you reference
other models,
which means the entire
lineage graph or lineage
system is preserved with
DBT invisible, which
is very nice for maintaining
all of these queries.
And also, if you use
the schema.yaml file,
you can generate docs
just out of the box.
And that will really allow
new [INAUDIBLE] analysts
that are just
coming in, and they
need to get to know
your schema really well.
It will really help them
to have that as a resource
to figure out how to run the
queries, what query [INAUDIBLE]
tables to look at, et cetera.
Then finally, you should
also definitely adopt
the GDPR strategy.
So two examples-- but
it's really up to you,
ultimately, how you
want to approach this.
But one could be you add
a method to the end point,
and then you route
all your events
that contain personal
identifiable information
only to your data warehouse.
So you avoid blob storage.
Because at that point, all of
that data that is sensitive
is in a SQL kind
of like ecosystem.
So you can run select
star from exports
and delete from for any
forget me kind of requests.
Alternatively, if you
use the batching setup,
what you could do is you
set a retention policy
on the first bucket for
four to eight weeks.
And then when the
batching stuff comes in,
for instance with Dataflow, you
have the data in memory again.
And that's where you can then do
any scrubbing or anonymization
of that data before
you then move it over
into its final resting place.
But then you can kind of
cope with it like that.
So that is everything.
Thanks for watching the video.
I hope you find it informative.
And if you have any questions
about it or suggestions,
then, yeah, feel free
to go to our website,
find out the forms,
leave a question there.
Or find me on LinkedIn and
just ping me a message,
and I will get back to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]